hey guys welcome to a brand new video
today I'm going to be going over the top
five money making methods that also give
you a very good amount of experience so
this will be kind of focused on scaling
money making methods but really anything
goes
I know these are my personal picks
they're not necessarily the absolute
best ones in the game plus they're kind
of based off of things that I can
actually do as opposed to just giving
you a bunch of wiki pages to look at or
something like that okay I keep that in
mind but anyway hope you guys enjoy and
let's get started
now coming in at number five is just
actually fletching IQ longbows out of
you longbows unstrung and bowstrings a
really easy method to do but it actually
gives upwards of a hundred and ninety
cakes being our four really paying
attention plus it gives you about two
hundred and fifty k GP per hour ad so
it's an excellent choice for leveling up
your fletching are really good money at
least for how accessible it is it does
require seventy fletching but honestly
that's not that high comparative to
other skills it doesn't actually take
very long to level up your fletching so
yeah 250 kg per hour isn't
groundbreaking by any means but
considering you getting close to 200 K
xp for our I would say it's worth it
plus it is reasonably afk obviously not
that much only about 10 seconds at a
time but it's really not that clique
intensive plus to get those experience
so anyway that's number five coming in
at number four is actually a very
underrated method that not a lot of
people use and that is the spin flax
Bell it is on the lunar spell book and
you will need seventy six magic to
actually cast it but it gives you around
65 K magic and crafting experience per
hour which are two generally expensive
skills to train normally and on top of
that currently we're actually profiting
about 200 K an hour and that's not
always like this but very frequently
I've noticed it does tend to actually
give you a profit which is really good
for how a little magical but you
relatively need for it anyway so here we
just did a couple cast is to price check
the amount here as we got fifteen
thousand four hundred
the bowstrings - 8 0 80 - 27 24 this
little transaction down here so 4600 and
we did 20 casts so we're getting about
230 GP / cast and you can do about 900
an hour you could do more but that's a
little more in the ballpark and so it
comes out to about 207 k plus you're
getting a hundred and thirty 240 K
experience and your other skills which i
think is really good and why I put it at
number four coming in number three is
humidifying clay I know this one is not
my favorite method English because of
how click intensive it is but it does
provide about 500k GP per hour now it
only gives about 50k XP per hour and
that is if you are really paying
attention I using Bank fillers and
making sure pan temperature clicks you
can still expect 400 to 500 K an hour
doing this and I think there's a
probably most useful application of the
humidify spell as a rise out thing to
spell is to useful maybe except for
humidifying plant pots but anyway yet
all you got to do is have 68 magic for
the humidify spell Angele need to been a
lunar spell book as well as recommended
is a steam at battle staff or his team
staff as you don't really waste any more
time with runes and this is kind of more
important for this because you will want
to optimize the amount of inventory
space you have because it actually just
does the full inventory no matter how
many clay you actually have their see
entire inventory if you had one clay
would still cast don't link invert one
which is not ideal
sometimes this method will reach upwards
of 700 K an hour and that's kind of why
I put it above the other one even though
the boat string method is a little more
preferred for me and this one does
actually grant more money per hour
usually that come in at number two is
watching Diamond Bowl tips now this
calls to be done with Ruby Bowl tips as
well but the profit and the experience
is a little bit less as we'll be doing
it with the diamond vault tips now what
you'll need is 65 fletching to do this
and
you can actually combine almost 25,000
of these an hour so it's a very quick
combination but anyway all you do is buy
Andaman bolts and diamond bolt tips off
the ground exchange and go ahead and
combine them and you just make 10 sets
and that's pretty much it for the
experience rates you're looking at close
to a hundred and ninety K an hour and
for the GP per hour does vary quite a
bit just based on the margin so we'll go
see what we get today but probably the
average you get about 500 k plus an hour
at doing this method but with all that
experience as well it says probably a
very earned number-two spot but we'll go
ahead and just check what we got today
okay so we're settling is off for four
hundred and twenty six K and we bought
the pieces 496 - 213 so we made 17 K and
that was only one thousand bolt so if we
multiply that by 25 because that's how
many we can do roughly in that hour it
looks like we're making about 425 cave
right now that's pretty average and the
one thing you have to keep in mind for
this is you do have to be aware of the
buying limit for these is I think ten
thousand and to do a full hours worth
we'll have to do a little bit of
pre-planning but it is definitely worth
it and that is number two and coming in
at number one is going to be enchanting
level five jewelry and what that means
is basically dragon stone today I
decided to buy some dragon stone
bracelets to turn to combat bracelets
but more consistently can do dragon
stone amulets turning those into glories
and basically you can get about 130 K
magic experience an hour the profit
varies wildly and you do need to spend a
bit of time ahead of time just find the
items but they buy it quicker than you
would imagine
and basically all you need is a mud bath
laughs or a mud snaps and some cosmic
runes and you're just going to go ahead
and enchant like anything else it's a
little clique intensive but I'd say it's
worth it because the experience rates
are extremely high and if you can profit
getting any amount of magic experience
as always
ranae's so yeah he just goes through
each every one of these and again can't
either rate enough that you do want to
check the price of everything before you
try this I had to go through all of the
Dragons own jewellery before I found one
that was reasonably good but I would
stick to amulets and bracelets do
occasionally work and the Rings I do
work as well and the Rings in glory
definitely are traded the most okay we
just finished up the last inventory of
the combat bracelet still go ahead and
withdraw the sixty unenchanted combat
bracelets okay so here's the history
here we bought them for 18 point 1 K and
some cosmic runes so we tried to price
check it earlier and while it does have
a lot traded it actually didn't have a
sell offer to come through okay we'll
try checking the combat bracelet again
and once again actually no one is buying
it even though it does trade pretty
frequently alright so we just checked on
GE tracker here and we're just gonna
pick a reasonable price to sell them at
and we'll do it for maybe nineteen point
five K and call it a day even though we
might be able to get higher I'd say
there's a little more fair for a test
19500 and we'll saw the off okay we'll
be back when they have sold okay we sold
off all the combat bracelets now would
it be kind of lucky and sold them for
about nineteen point five K which i
think is still a little bit above what
you might get normally but still we'll
have a look at what we profited now and
then maybe just telling it down a little
bit for what the average would be so
let's go have a look we sold them all
for one one seventy and we bought the
prerequisite ingredients for one zero
eight six and four K leaving us with in
the eighty key profit so now that was 60
of them so per ad bracelet we were
getting 1.3 K which is amazing since
into about 15 under of these in an hour
so as it stands if I'd done all this
that would have been about 2 mil which I
wouldn't say is extremely likely so
let's say we sold them for about 19
cakes that seemed a little more
reasonable
so 19 K I have we've done that that
would've been 1,900 times 60 B 1 140
instead and I'm going to take off one
zero eight six zero
sixty I guess I can click and 3840
leaving this with fifty point one can
profit divide that by 60 and multiply
that by fifteen hundred and we're still
getting over a mill an hour
looks like 1250 K which is really good
considering you get about 130 km magic
experience on top of that anyway guys
that is my top five money making methods
that also give you a really good
experience and hope you enjoyed if you
did don't forget to toss the video a
like and I will see you guys in the next
video
[Music]